- Lemme take my beanie off,
take my beanie off a little bit.
- [Interviewer] Okay. Cool.
All right, I'm sorry,
what was your name again?
- [Michael] Michael.
- [Interviewer] Michael.
Michael, where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Michael] The East side of LA.
- [Interviewer] The East Side?
- Mmh hmm, 43rd and San Pedro.
- [Interviewer] And, you grew
up with both your parents?
- Yes.
Well, stepdad and my mum.
- Stepdad and your mum?
He raised me, got me my
first job, first car,
you know, things like that, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
- Well, mom did drugs and
alcohol on the weekends,
and pop smoked sherm.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Yeah, but they did their best.
Yeah, they did their best, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how did
that play out with you as a kid?
- I learnt a lot.
(Interviewer chuckles)
I felt alone a lot, I didn't feel loved,
you know 'cause all I
got was ass beatings.
Can I say that?
- Yeah.
Ass beatings and withdrawing.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Very tough kid.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, do you
have brothers and sisters?
- Mmh hmm.
- [Interviewer] The whole
family got it? All the kids?
- No, my baby brother, he
was like the chosen child.
Never got in trouble,
he might've got one or two whoopings,
the best of clothes, he ate real good,
he got the most attention.
My two sisters, they were girls,
so they got, you know,
little hand-me-down dresses
and you know, they didn't
get the beatings either,
seemed like I was the only one,
like the black sheep in the family, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And then what age were you
when you left home?
- Excuse me?
- [Interviewer] What age
were you when you left home?
- Ooh,
like 15, 14 and a half, 15.
- Oh really?
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Did
you finish high school?
- No, I got my GED in prison though.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And so
where'd you go at 14?
- From friend's house to girl's houses,
slept in abandoned buildings,
parks,
stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- You know places like that.
- [Interviewer] That's a rough childhood.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So you did
prison time at what age?
- Ooh, I went to YA at 16.
I started doing real prison
time from 18 on up, I'm 50 now.
- [Interviewer] What
were you in prison for?
- My first case was direct sales,
and my second case was a robbery.
My third case was assault
with a deadly weapon,
fourth case with a GBI,
that's like assault with a deadly weapon,
with great bodily injury,
and then drug cases and drug cases, yes.
- [Interviewer] And do
you have kids of your own?
- Yes, I have three, they're all grown.
- [Interviewer] Did you raise them?
You were in prison for a while is that?
- Prison, yes, or drugs, yes.
- [Interviewer] Are you still
in contact with your kids?
- Of course.
- Yeah?
Of course, yes.
And then, so how'd you end
up down here in Skid Row?
- Well, I got out of prison,
they put me in a drug rehab,
they had bed bugs in the
place, so I just left.
And I've been downtown ever since.
That was since last time I saw you.
Remember last time I saw you?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yeah, since then.
- [Interviewer] And then, so
your drug out here is what?
- Cocaine.
- [Interviewer] Do you use crack?
- Crack, it's not cocaine
no more, it's crack.
- It's crack yeah.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how long
have you been using crack?
- Since I was 18.
- [Interviewer] Since 18, and
then in prison (indistinct)?
- In prison I didn't do anything.
- [Interviewer] You didn't do anything?
- No, didn't do anything.
- [Interviewer] You were clean in prison?
- Yes. Had to.
- Whether you liked it...
Whether you liked it or not.
You had to stay strong,
you had to stay strong.
- [Interviewer] What's that like?
That's gotta be rough,
sitting in a cell, just withdrawing right?
- I didn't withdraw , I
withdrawed in the County jail.
I came to the point of it
being like home, you know?
When I would get out, it's
like a vacation, you know?
So I would go back home,
come out on a vacation,
go back home, come out on a vacation.
Yeah, it became home.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- More so than the streets.
- [Interviewer] And how long have you been
down here in Skid Row?
- About four months, four or five months?
Four or five months, four or five months.
- [Interviewer] And where
are you sleeping, in a tent?
- Tent. That's the new thing, tents.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, yeah,
when I first came down here,
there were no tents, maybe one or two.
- Yeah, now they're everywhere.
- [Interviewer] Everybody had
a cardboard box, remember?
- I remember that.
- [Interviewer] You just laid
down on your cardboard box.
- Yes, cover up with a cardboard
box and go to sleep, yes.
- [Interviewer] Now
everybody's got a tent.
- Yes, that's the big thing
now. That's the big thing now.
But I'm staying with a
female, and it's her tent,
and I'm waiting to get my
money so I can buy me a tent,
and, you know, do all
the rest of the stuff
that comes along with it, yes.
- [Interviewer] And
then where do you think
your life will go from here?
Do you have any plans?
- To be honest, not really.
This is it.
- [Interviewer] You
think you'll stay here?
- Yeah, I know it's sad to say,
but, kind of gave up, you
know, I kinda gave up.
- [Interviewer] Wait, do
you think the prison time,
and the lack of education and-
- I got my GED in prison.
- [Interviewer] Okay. That's good.
But you know, I mean do you
think there's so many kind of
counts against you that it's just,
it's hard for you to just
get your life together
and get back on track?
- Well, actually it's the drugs.
- [Interviewer] It's the drugs?
- It's the drugs, it's the drugs.
I've tried everything
from prison to programs
to church, hospitals, mental hospitals.
I've tried everything.
They give me, it's called POC,
Prolia outpatient clinic.
They give me an injection now,
that's supposed to curve
cravings, it doesn't work.
So I'm just here.
- [Interviewer] You don't see any chance
of breaking free of them?
The whole crack (indistinct)?
- No. No, I don't,
I've came to the point to
accept it, just accept it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, and
there's no way to be functional
and have a job and show up
for work and do all that
with a crack addict?
- I mean, I could, I could,
I could, yes I could.
But I receive SSI.
- [Interviewer] Okay-
- I receive, so.
- [Interviewer] Okay, so that just-
- Keep me going.
Keeps you going.
Keep me going, keep me
going, keep me going, yes.
I know that's sad to
say, but it's my life.
- [Interviewer] Do your
kids know you're down here?
- Mmh hmm, my family knows where I'm at.
If they wanna come see me or
pick me up, they can come.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, does
that happen some times?
- Yes, oh yes, as a matter of fact
it happened two weeks ago.
My sister came in and picked
me up, took me to her house,
cleaned me up and you
know, shave and fed me
for a couple of weeks and all that stuff.
But I came back down here.
- [Interviewer] You got
Christmas next week,
you gonna get together with them then?
- Yes, my kids. Yes, with my kids, yes.
- [Interviewer] You still got a little
of your family (indistinct)-
- [Michael] Yes, I
still have a little bit.
I still have a little bit, you know.
But they watch me when
I come over their house
and it makes me feel uncomfortable.
I've never stolen anything from them,
but it makes me feel uncomfortable.
Everybody's eyes on me, you
know, they looking at me,
look at my hands and
you know my face, and-
- [Interviewer] What kind
of traumatic experiences
have happened throughout your life?
- Well, when I was a kid,
about eight years old,
my babysitter, she was
a female, she raped me.
I thought it was how it was
supposed to be, it felt good.
As I got older, I went to prison.
my celly, he got me drunk, overpowered me,
and he raped me, he raped me.
I didn't talk about that for year...
I haven't talked about that,
that's not something you talk about,
but it didn't kill me,
it made me stronger.
You know, it's harder
for me to trust people.
And to be honest, I
kind of grew to like it.
You know, that's just the way it is,
you know, it's just the way it is.
And it affects me to this day.
- [Interviewer] It
affects your relationships
with women?
- Women, yes.
- Only have relationships with women.
Men is just a, that's it, but-
- [Interviewer] So you have relationships
with both men and women now?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] But which
is your preference then?
- Women.
Women?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] How has it affected you?
So you're more aggressive, you're rougher?
- Yeah, I'm aggressive,
I'm aggressive, yeah.
And they tend to like
it like that (laughs).
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
some of them (indistinct)-
- Yes they do, yes they do.
- [Interviewer] And some think it's right.
- Yes they do.
- [Interviewer] It's an interesting way
of looking at it.
- Yes it is.
- It's real interesting, it is.
- [Interviewer] Do you
look back at your life
and regret like certain
decisions or certain things
that happened to you?
- Yes, yes.
- [Interviewer] When you were
younger that just kind of
put you on this path
instead of a better one?
- Yes, I had the opportunity
to go stay with my auntie,
and all her kids are normal, you know,
as they say, "What's normal?"
But they're pretty normal,
have jobs, wives, homes.
You know, good jobs and
all that kind of stuff.
I think that would have been better for me
but I did not go, I didn't wanna go.
I was too stuck up under my mom.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- Then I was living a carefree life.
Come in when I want, excuse me,
come in when I want to, do drugs, drink.
Have the women over and stuff like that.
No responsibilities.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] No responsibilities?
- No responsibilities.
- [Interviewer] It's tempting isn't it?
- Yeah, but I need responsibilities.
I need that, I need that.
- [Interviewer] I think it
gives your life meaning?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And like
grounds you and gives you
like reason to push forward.
- Push forward, it grounds you,
it grounds you, yes it does.
It grounds you.
- [Interviewer] That temptation
to not have any responsibility
it takes you apart.
- Yes, it does, yes, it does.
It really does.
- It's like a drug.
- Yeah, and then you get used
to it having no respons...
Down here, no responsibility.
- [Interviewer]
(indistinct) Gotta pay rent,
I gotta like get a job,
(indistinct) responsible, like fuck that.
- Yes, yes, yes.
(indistinct)
- [Interviewer] It's
easier to just ignore them.
- Yeah it is, it is, it is.
But that's normal to
have those things in life
you know, that's a normal.
What is normal?
But that's what people expect
us to do and have, you know.
Those are the things we
supposed to get out of life
so we can live comfortably
when we get old, you know.
Look at my face, I'm almost there, man.
I'm 50, I'm almost done-
- [Interviewer] I think
man is meant to work-
- Yes, of course.
- [Interviewer] It makes it you happy.
As long as you're doing
something that you feel like-
- You love to do.
- You love to do better.
That's even better.
- [Interviewer] You know
you're building a better life
for your family or you're
doing something constructive,
that just gives your, like it grounds you
it gives you meaning, makes you happy.
- [Michael] Yes, yes it does, yes it does.
Miss it, it gives you peace.
- [Interviewer] And down
here you're hiding out
from all of the above.
- All of the above, yes, yes.
- [Interviewer] All right, well thank you
so much for talking to me.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] Good luck
with everything, and have
a nice Christmas.
- (laughs) Thank you, thank you.